[Musik]
herzlich willkommen aus Köln live zum
internationalen frühschoen zwei Wochen
sind seit den Terrorangriffen der Hamas
auf Israel vergangen und die Welt blickt
sorgenvoll auf die Situation der
Menschen Vorort droht der Krieg zu
eskalieren und zu einem mer frontenkrieg
zu werden mit sebaren folgen am
Wochenende gab es immerhin die Nachricht
dass zwei Geiseln freigelassen wurden
und humanitäre Hilfe nach Gaza starten
konnte ein Zeichen der Hoffnung so nennt
es die deutsche Außenministerin am
Samstag haben mehrere LKW von Ägypten
aus erste Hilfsgüter in den Gazastreifen
transportiert die internationalen
Bemühungen sollen eine Ausweitung des
Konflikts verhindern aber auch eine
humanitäre Katastrophe im abgeriegelten
Gaza
die Zeit ist gekommen zum Handeln um
diesen schrecklichen Albtraum zu beenden
um eine Zukunft aufzubauen die den
Träumen der Kinder palästiners Israels
der Region und unserer Welt würdig
ist doch noch ist der Albtraum
allgegenwärtig der brutale Großangriff
der Hamas hat alte Wunden wieder
aufgerissen infolge der Angriffe beklagt
Israel mehr als 1400 tote während Israel
die Armee in Stellung bringt laufen die
atischen Bemühungen auf Hochtouren in
Ägypten in den USA und vor
Ort israel hat die Pflicht sich zu
wehren und muss sicherstellen dass so
etwas nicht noch einmal passiert aber
die Art und Weise wie Israel dies tut
ist wichtig insbesondere müssen die
Operationen im Einklang mit dem
Völkerrecht durchgeführt
werden noch immer seien mehr als 200
Geiseln in den Händen der Hamas
Eskalation in Nahost die Welt ringt um
Lösungen
das ist unser Thema heute und ich freue
mich sehr es mit diesen Gästen zu
besprechen bei uns ist Kat Jun armipur
sie ist Publizistin und
Islamwissenschaftlerin der Universität
in Köln und bei uns ist Katherine Küver
asbru sie ist Analystin und Publizistin
bei der
Bertelsmannstiftung und Konstantin
goldensweig ist bei uns erst freier
Journalist aus Russland und Philip
helmann Engel ist bei uns der
Chefredakteur der Jüdischen Allgemeinen
herzlich willkommen Herr Engel zwei
Wochen sind vergangen seit den
Terrorangriffen die Situation ist nach
wie vor extrem besorgniserregend wie
geht's ihnen und hat es ein kleines
bisschen Hoffnung gemacht dass immerhin
zwei Geiseln freigelassen wurden sie
mein mir ganz persönlich ja wir stehen
wie Juden in Deutschland nach wie vor
extrem noch unter dem Eindruck dieses ja
blutigen Massakers es wurde erwähnt 1400
Juden an einem Tag wurden in Israel
brutalst abgeschlachtet man muss sich
das vergegenwärtigen das ist der
dunkelste Tag in in der Geschichte
Israels ähm aber auch der dunkelste Tag
in der Geschichte des jüdischen Volkes
seit
1945 und ja sie haben persönlich gefragt
ich antworte persönlich also wir wachen
mit diesen Videos mit diesen Nachrichten
die aus Israel kommen auf wir gehen
damit zu Bett und das hinterlässt tiefe
Spuren und parallel das will ich auch
immer wieder betonen unser Herz blutet
auch für die palätinensische
Zivilbevölkerung die in Geiselhaft
genommen wird von der Hamas und die
Freilassung der zwei US-Amerikaner ist
das etwas was zumindest ein
Hoffnungsschimmer aus ja es ist auf
jeden Fall ein Hoffnungsschimmer wir
bekommen ja auch mit unsere Redaktion
über
vielfältige Kontakte und Kanäle dass die
diplomatischen Bemühungen auf Hochtouren
laufen man muss sich aber auch
vergegenwärtigen es sind über 200
Geiseln die Festgenommen verschleppt
deportiert worden sind von der Hermas
unter anderem auch ein 8 Monate altes
Baby frauenalte Holocaust
Überlebende das was wir hören die
Hoffnung ist groß aber die Perspektive
ist nicht die allerbeste ist oder um es
klar zu sagen ziemlich düster wie
bewerten sie es Frau Klüber eschbuck die
freigelassenen zwei Geiseln sind
US-Amerikaner was für ein Zeichen ist
diese Freilassung also erstmal ich
stimme meinem vorrner völlig ein das
waren zwei Wochen der absoluten
Grausamkeit wir erleben in den
politischen Reaktionen überhaupt den
Reaktionen insgesamt weiterhin dass sie
natürlich mit Trauer gefüllt sind dass
sie mit Hass gefüllt sind dass viele
Emotionen im Spiel sind ich glaube wir
als Analysten des ganzen Geschehens
müssen erst mit Menschlichkeit mit
Empathie an die Situation herangehen
bevor wir uns quasi mit den politischen
Umständen beschäftigen können also ich
glaube im ersten Moment gilt unser
Mitgefühl unsere Menschlichkeit den
Menschen in der Region
die jetzt schweres schweres leisten
jeden Tag äh für die USA war das jetzt
eine Woche der großen Fragestellungen
ist die USA weit weiterhin der System
schalt und Angelpunkt für die
Weltpolitik ist die USA das was Joe
Biden in seiner Rede an die Nation immer
wieder betont hat dieses geflügelte Wort
von Madeline Albright die unersetzliche
Nation in diesem Moment das heißt die
USA hat in diesem Konflikt mehreres zu
leisten einerseits natürlich das was wir
zuerst gehört haben die uneingeschränkte
Solidarität mit Israel aber im gleichen
Atemzug eben auch und eben besonders
auch in dieser Rede eine eine ganz klare
und ein ganz klarer Betonung auf die
humanitäre Situation in Gaza auf das
internationale Völkerrecht auf die
Genfer Konvention
einen ganz bestimmten Druck natürlich
auch auf die ganze Situation der Geiseln
insgesamt also all das muss geleistet
werden und umgekehrt haben wir eine
reisediplomatie gesehen gerade von
Anthony blinken die einem Herr Kissinger
am Ende des jomkipur Krieges nachkommt
also wirklich ein ein Reisen durch die
Region um quasi dieses
Eskalationspotenzial abzudrehen dass die
Geiseln speziell sind natürlich zwei
Dinge die Amerikaner haben
unterschwellig und es ist eine sehr sehr
schwierige innenpolitische Situation für
den Präsidenten auch ein
innenpolitisches Signal zu senden
einerseits hat die USA mit zwei
Sondergesandten gearbeitet mit FBI vor
Ort mit Katar sehr stark verhandelt also
alles diplomatische Gewicht reingeworfen
in diese Verhandlungen aber gleichzeitig
gesagt es muss natürlich über
amerikanische Staatsbürger hinausgehen
und ob das gelingt das werden wir in den
nächsten paar Tagen hoffentlich paar
Wochen sehen wenn sich der Konflikt
einschränken lässt wenn sich die große
Bodenoffensive noch abhalten lässt genau
darüber werden wir sprechen ein
Vertreter Katars hat ja gesagt es wird
weitere Freilassung geben und in der Tat
laufen diplomatische Bemühungen an allen
Stellen es gab jetzt diesen
internationalen Friedensgipfel jetzt am
Wochenende allerdings ohne Beteiligung
Israels und ohne die USA was ist dabei
herumgekommen aus ihrer Sicht na ja so
viel jetzt im Moment noch nicht es
müssen weitere Bemühungen aufgenommen
werden und im Moment können wir ja nun
wirklich noch nicht sagen dass sich
allzu viel an Hoffnungsschimmer
abzeichnet also ich sehe da eher die
Gefahr einer großen Eskalation und die
Amerikaner haben ja sehr deutlich
gemacht dass sie das Vorhaben zu
verhindern mit ihrer doch sehr starken
Präsenz jetzt und dass sie Iran sehr
sehr deutlich machen Iran möge jetzt
bitte die Füße
stillhalten die Füße stillhalten Putin
hat sich natürlich auch geäußert hat mit
allen Vertretern im Nahen Osten
telefoniert seine Sorge geäußert und
auch deine Sorge über das Wohl der
Zivilisten in Gaza sehr stark betont wie
haben sie seine Reaktion
warahgenommen na ja wir können das
eigentlich mit den Ereignissen vor 22
Jahren vergleichen
als der schreckliche Terroranschlag in
den USA stattgefunden hat war Putin Bein
also einer der ersten staatsauberholten
der den Präsidenten Bush angerufen hat
und sein Beileid mitgeteilt hat diesmal
hat Putin das gleiche mit einer sehr
spürbaren Pause gemacht und explizit
sich auf die Art geäußert dass es
keinesfalls aussehen würde dass Russland
an der Seite die Opfer von einem
schrecklichen Terroranschlag von Hamas
stünde und das ist sehr bemerkenswert
natürlich wird Putin
in seiner jetzigen Lage
versuchen noch mal die
Aufmerksamkeit des Westens und der
ganzen Welt von seinen Kriegsverbrechen
in Ukraine abzulenken und als eine Art
friedensvermittler darzustellen was
wiederum ein bisschen schizophren klingt
ein Kriegsverbrecher der als
friedensvermittler
daasteht und drittens anderseits
wird er natürlich ein gewisses Problem
damit haben weil so so eine Diktatur die
wir jetzt in Russland haben geht stets
ein sehr starker Antisemitismus einher
inwiefern macht sich das bemerkbar das
macht sich sehr bemerkbar indem unser
Staatsoberhaupt sich nicht mehr schiemt
gewisse Witze über die Juden zu machen
im Fernsehen oder dass seine Gouverneure
und
Abgeordnete das sind die Nachrichten der
letzten Tage beispielsweise verbieten
Rock und popmusikanten die direkt Israel
unterstützen ihre Konzerte zu geben oder
das beispielsweise der chechenian
Herrscher kadirov ganz offen Hamas
unterstützt und sagt Hamas soll gewinnen
das ist die Stufe vom Antisemitismus die
den wir in Russland seit vielen vielen
Jahren nicht hatten und in dem
Zusammenhang nicht ihnen sondern
außenpolitisch betrachtet wird wird es
für
Putin wie zynisch seine Äußerungen
klingen mögen doch sehr schwer als
diesen Vermittler
dazustehen sprechen wir gleich auch noch
im Detail drüber jetzt auch an diesem
Wochenende starteten ja die
Hilfslieferungen zu den Menschen im
gaserastreifen Medikamente Nahrung vor
allen Dingen Wasser ausministerin
berburg hat das als kleines Zeichen der
Hoffnung für die Menschen vor Ort
bezeich
wird daraus mehr oder besteht nach wie
vor natürlich einfach auch die Sorge
Israels dass diese Transporte
missbraucht werden seitens der Hammers
diese Sorge besteht aus meiner Sicht
auch aus guten Grund
in den vergangenen Jahren als
Außenministerin wärburg steht ja auch
gerade zurzeit immer noch sehr stark in
der Kritik mit ihrer Äußerung dass sie
sagt wir leisten humanitäre Hilfe nicht
dass das humanitäre Hilfe geleistet wird
ist vollkommen richtig aber es wird nach
wie vor immer noch nicht geknüpft an
Bedingung und wenn wir uns die letzten
Jahre anschauen deutschland ist einer
der größten Geldgeber für Organisation
auch im Gazastreifen für
Hilfsorganisation und diese Hilfsgelder
das muss man so klar sagen werden
missbraucht und zwar missbraucht für den
Terror der Hamas und ja da sehen wir
immer noch wirklich eine große
Schwierigkeit also
das das Anliegen ist sehr sehr ehrenwert
aber die Umsetzung ist ziemlich
problematisch weil vielleicht ist auch
gar nicht sicher bestellt werden kann
dass eben diese Gelder nur für Nahrung
nur für Bildung und nur für Wasser
ausgegeben werden können ja das ist ein
riesen Problem das eine sind die
Hilfsgelder das andere sind jetzt diese
konkreten Lieferungen verstehe ich sie
richtig dass sie sagen diese konkreten
Lieferung von Wasser und Nahrung sollten
auch an Bedingung geknüpft werden na ja
also es gibt ja schon
ja das Mittel der Diplomatie um auch den
politischen Kräften im Gazastreifen
spricht der Hamas deutlich zu machen äh
wir unterstützen die Zivilbevölkerung
aber das ist eben geknüpft an
Bedingungen und alles was mit Terror zu
tun hat und so weiter dann kann man das
natürlich auch und finde ich sollte man
auch als Deutschland mit der Geschichte
Deutschlands als ähm Druckmittel
einsetzen nicht nicht um äh ganz bewusst
natürlich die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza
zu schädigen es gibt noch andere
politische Kräfte in der Region ja die
natürlich der Zivilbevölkerung helfen
Ägypten USA und andere aber ich finde da
M Deutschland und auch insbesondere
Außenministerin berbock offener und
klarer sprechen und das ist ja
eigentlich auch ihr Markenkern dass sie
sagt ne wir reden auch in Richtung
Diktaturen und Terroristen Klartext die
Konis aber die lassen sich und ich
glaube das haben wir jetzt verschiedench
in den letzten Tagen gehört die Konvois
an sich die würden sich kontrollieren
lassen die sind ja physisch vor Ort
selbst die UN wir haben Herrn
gutherrisch in der Anmoderation zur
Sendung noch mal gehört hat gesagt auch
da würden sie sich stark engagieren
nämlich die Kois selber zu kontrollieren
und die Tatsache dass der Lastwagen nach
Lastwagen an der Grenze steht sagt ja
schon dass wir dass das dringend
benötigt wird ich glaube die 20
Lastwagen die wirken für viele
Palästinenser im in diesem ersten Moment
auch erstmal zynisch das ist einfach
viel zu wenig wir haben Situationen
gesehen wo viermal fünfm so viel
Lastwagen quasi täglich gebraucht wurden
und wir sehen jetzt allein durch die
Verschiebungen im gaserastreifen wo an
welchen Stellen welche Dinge gebraucht
werden es sind kaum noch Krankenhäuser
funktionsfähig Menschen werden nachts
operiert werden werden bei bei werden
umgekehrt eben nur bei Tageslicht
operiert ohne die nötigen Hilfsmittel
und und und dass diese Hilfsmittel
dringend gebraucht werden und dass das
der erste Verhandlungserfolg der
Amerikaner gegenüber der israelischen
Regierung war steht glaube ich ohne
Zweifel die Konvois an sich werden sich
kontrollieren lassen das muss viel
schneller gehen glaube ich wenn man
wirklich eine großflächige humanitäre
Krise ganz unabhängig dessen ob es eine
wirkliche Bodenoffensive geben wird wenn
man das leisten möchte und da schließt
sich der Ring der internationalen
Gemeinschaft quasi um diese Lieferung
scheinbar ist das etwas was zynisch
wahrgenommen wird gerade in den Staaten
die ohnehin ja sehr Israel feindlich
eingestellt sind und auf der Seite der
Hamas stehen wird es zynisch Wargen
genommen die 20 LKW oder als ein
Zeichen dazu die Situation zumindest der
Menschen vor Ort ein wenig zu sehen
vielleicht nicht unbedingt als zynisch
aber auf jeden Fall als viel zu wenig
also natürlich sagen alle dass das von
schon viel viel früher hätte passieren
müssen wobei das natürlich auch Problem
der Ägypter ist aber es wird auf jeden
Fall so wahrgenommen als sei die
internationale Gemeinschaft nicht
wirklich dahinterher und würde nicht
genügend Druck ausüben damit den
Menschen der Zivilbevölkerung in Gasa
wirklich geholfen wird sondern man sieht
eher die Seite dass auch diese Zivil
Bevölkerung mit den Geiselhaft genommen
wird dass nicht genug getrennt wird
zwischen dem Terror der Hamas und den
unschuldigen Menschen in ähm in in Gaza
dass denen quasi mit vorgeworfen wird
sie sollen doch entweder auf die Straße
gehen oder hätten die Hamas nicht wählen
sollen oder sie sollten sich irgendwie
erheben gegen die Hamas was aber hier
nur nicht möglich ist Gasa ist ein
einziges Gefängnis und die Menschen
werden vor allem von der Hamas in den
Geiselhaft genommen und dass ich da die
internationale Gemeinschaft nicht
stärker positioniert und nicht stärker
gegen ausspricht das wird schon als sehr
große Vernachlässigung wahgenommen das
macht in der Tat die Situation aus dass
die Menschen in Gaza in diesem ganz
dicht besiedelten Streifen ähm ja selbst
wenn Sie es möchten ähm Schwierigkeiten
haben sich wirklich zu trennen weil die
Hamas ja auch gerade so vorgeht dass sie
menschliche Schutzschilde tatsächlich
benutzt israel hat jetzt angekündigt in
die nächste Phase des Krieges eintreten
zu wollen was bedeutet das genau na ja
israel hat verschiedene Ziele Israel
möchte sich künftig viel viel besser ja
richtigerweise notwendigerweise gegen
den Terror der Hamas schützen seine
eigenen Bürger schützen weitere Angriff
für unterbinden sie wollen alle unsere
Kanäle in Israel sagen das wirklich die
Hamas ein für alle Mal zerstören die wie
kann das gelingen na ja das ist jetzt
die große Frage also die Bodenoffensive
wird kommen das ist ja keine
ja Aktion die man von einem Tag auf den
anderen machen kann über 300.000
Reservisten wurden jetzt eingezogen und
vorbereitet
alle Experten sagen aber auch dass das
ja auf beiden Seiten sehr sehr blutig
werden sie wird
sowohl die
israelischen S Daten werden einen hohen
Blutzoll
zahlen müssen auch wenn Israel wirklich
das ist nicht nur meine Privatmeinung
sondern auch ein empirischer Fakt die
moralischste Armee der Welt ist oder
einer der moralischen Armeen der Welt
ist wird Israel versuchen m ja die
Zahlen der Opfer auf palästinensischer
Seite auf bei der Zivilbevölkerung
versuchen möglichst gering zu halten
aber das wird klar sein da werden auch
schreckliche Bilder kommen und viele
Menschen werden sterben aber das muss
auch gesagt werden israel hat keine
anderen Option also es gibt eine
Terrororganisation im Gazastreifen die
Hamas die möglichst nicht nur alle
Israelis ermorden will sondern alle
Juden weltweit israel hat keine andere
Option als ja versuchen diesen Terror zu
bekämpfen und warum Verzögerung der
Bodenoffensive vielleicht einfach mal in
die Runde gefragt was sind die Gründe
dafür dass ich das
verzögert also ich glaube im besten Fall
ist es weil
weil noch mal gesehen wird oder im
besten Fall gelernt wird von den
internationalen Erfahrungen Herr Biden
hat sowohl in der Region wie auch in
seiner Ansprache an die Nation noch mal
erwähnt dass wir wir hatten den 11
September schon ins Gespräch gebracht
nach dem 11 September die Amerikaner
große außenpolitische Fehler gemacht
haben sich haben leiten lassen
von Hass Vergeltung von Fehlinformation
wir sehen jetzt gerade auch in diesem
Konflikt wie viel Desinformation
überall hingelangt wie wichtig daher
saubere
geheimdientinformation sind wir haben in
Israel ein einen ein wirklich
vorbildlichen geheimdienstapparat der
aber trotzdem dieses grauenhafte
Massaker nicht hat verhindern können
also und das das ist den Israelis auch
bewusst da sind im Vorlauf auch einfach
Fehler gemacht worden in der Analyse und
ich glaube das ist ein Punkt auch zu
überlegen was kann wirklich erreicht
werden es ist in dem Sinne historisch
noch keine Terrororganisation durch
einen klassischen Militärschlag zerstört
worden außer vielleicht der der tamel
Tigers und selbst das kann an einem
unglaublichen Blutzoll also wir wissen
dass auch mittelfristig dann sie
Konsequenzen sind und dann kommt die
Fragestellung gleich was würde mit einem
Gasastreifen Passieren der entweder
entpopulisiert wird oder der quasi in
irgendeiner Weise zerstört wird welche
Verwaltungsstruktur bekommt das was
passiert dann und wenn man sich noch mal
die Bevölkerungsstruktur des
gaserstreifens anschaut hauptsächlich
Kinder und Jugendliche würde man sich
denn nicht trotzdem durch einen
grauenhaften Militärschlag oder einen
der mit grauenhaften folgen eine nächste
Generation von Terroristen oder
Widerstandskämpfern so wie es dann in
dem doktus vielleicht gefasst wird
heranziehen also gibt es einen Weg einen
Zyklus den wir jetzt schon
verschiedentlich gesehen haben bei Isis
bei unterschiedlichen oder bei rked da
bei unterschiedlichen terroristischen
Gruppen gibt es einen Weg diese Dinge
mitzudenken zu vermeiden genau
abzuschätzen weil und das wissen wir
natürlich alle Welt schaut zurzeit auf
diese Region schaut auf das äh wie sich
da die Konfliktparteien Verhalten und
das wiederum sie gibt Signalwirkung an
die großen Autokratien wir haben über
Russland gesprochen wir werden über
China sprechen und den Iran sowieso in
welchem Weltsystem wollen wir uns
eigentlich bewegen MSS den zustimmen in
dem
ich gerne hinzufügen würde dass also wir
reden nicht von den Rissen die durch
Israel und Gazastreifen gehen würden
sondern zum Teil durch die ganze Welt
einerseits schauen wie
was sich hier in Deutschland in
deutschen stäten in im Laufe den letzten
Wochen abläuft anderseits äh lassen uns
erinnern daran wie viele Energie wie
viele Bemühungen westliche Länder darin
investiert haben um den sogenannten
global South muslimische arabische
Länder davon zu überzeugen auf die Seite
beispielsweise der Ukraine zu stehen ja
jetzt scheint es so dass alle diese
Versuche wenn nicht vergebens waren dann
ist es sehr sehr knapp und äh um äh
diese äh
riesengroße Eskalationsspirale zu
vermeiden um nicht in einem globalen
Konflikt der viel viel weiter als sein
Gasastreifen ist zu landen muss man
wahrscheinlich mehrmals überlegen was
man tut und Hauptsache was das Ergebnis
wie das Ergebnis wie ist der
Game aussehen soll das ist die große
Frage diese Überlegungen laufen ja auch
was mich noch mal interessieren würde
die Hamas ist ja bei den Terrorangriffen
so geplant vorgegangen gab es denn oder
wie schätzen Sie es ein hat die Hamas
auch eine Strategie für all das was
jetzt kommt also eine Bodenoffensive
oder was Frau Klüber eschbuck schon
angesprochen hat was ist wenn es dann
noch mal zu einer Besatzung des
Gazastreifens käme oder m ähnliche
Konstellation gibt es das hat die
heramas das so durchdacht wie den
ursprünglichen Terrorangriff aus ihrer
Einschätzung das ist glaube ich eine
Frage für für Geheimdienstler also so
viel Einblick in die geheim in die die
Strukturen der heramas hat wohl keiner
im Moment also dass der Angriff sehr
genau geplant war und sehr genau
durchdacht war das ist ja inzwischen
klar das hätte man eigentlich auch
wissen können also selbst auf der
Website der Revolutionsgarden in Iran
stand schon im Juli dass sich die Führer
der Führer des Islamischen Jihad und der
Führer der herar in Teran getroffen
haben und die Revolutionsgarden haben
danach ein Statement rausgegeben und
haben gesagt wir haben
1600 quadratmer Werkstätten gebaut in
Gaza damit die Hamas einen solchen
Angriff aus voll führen kann also das
schinb das nicht mitbekommen hat ist ja
fast das das eigentlich komische an der
an der an der ganzen Geschichte also
diese angriffsplanung war absolut
detailliert und mit Sicherheit auch mit
Teran abgesprochen aber was jetzt die
weitere Strategie ist das das würde ich
bezweifeln wahrscheinlich sind sie sogar
selber überrascht worden davon wie in
Anführungszeichen erfolgreich sie mit
mit ihrem Angriff sein konnten und haben
die exit Strategie insofern nicht
entwickelt das ist ja eine Theorie dass
in der Tat möglicherweise auch die
Angreifer die Terroristen über
überrascht sein könnten weiten wir den
Blick vielleicht mal insofern als dass
es er auch jetzt schon zu
Raketenangriffen aus dem Libanon kommt
im Libanon mit der Hisbollah eine
Organisation die unterstützt wird vom
Iran genau da ist die Befürchtung dass
sich der Krieg ausweiten kann wie
schätzen Sie die Situation ein also zum
einen wird ja auch die hers ganz massiv
von Iran finanziert mit 30 Millionen im
Monat
und die Gefahr der Ausweitung ist
natürlich auch wieder eine große Frage
aber ich habe im Moment das Gefühl dass
Iran ja tatsächlich der bisherige Sieger
der ganzen Geschichte ist denn Iran will
natürlich dass Israel eingedämmt wird
wenn es so ist wie es vermutlich ist
dass Bibi Netanyahu längerfristig plant
iranische oder geplant hat iranische
Atomanlagen zu zerstören weil er das als
Gefahr für Israel sieht dann ist es
natürlich im Moment so dass Israel
erstmal so gefangen ist in den ganzen
Konstellationen dass daraus nicht viel
werden kann in Zukunft und Iran hat ja
eher die Strategie dass es seine Proxys
seine seine Verbündeten in der Region
nach vorne schickt deshalb ja die
Finanzierung von Hamas und Hisbollah und
den ganzen pro-iranischen Milizen im
Irak und den hutis im Jemen damit man
das im Prinzip alles nicht nicht selber
machen muss denn diese Finanzierung der
sogenannten Achse des Widerstandes das
liegt ja nicht daran dass man wirklich
ein Herz hat für die Palästinenser
sondern dass das eigentlich die größte
Absicherung des Regimes der Islamischen
Republik ist damit die dann entweder
sollte Iran angegriffen werden
eingesetzt werden können oder eben jetzt
um Israel in einen solchen Krieg zu
verwickeln und am besten noch in einen
Zweifrontenkrieg dann wenn die hisbolla
jetzt noch stärker eingreift das is
rechnen auch damit dass es zu diesem
stärkeren Eingreifen der hisbolla kommen
wird möglich ist
es also wir rechnen sehr sehr stark
damit also man muss sich
vergegenwertigen in den letzten 14 Tagen
gab es tagtäglich Angriffe aus dem
Norden von der hisbolla die maßgeblich
unterstützt wird unter anderem von dem
Iran von Iran Israel verfolgt eine zero
tolerance Politik in dem Moment wo
Raketen rüber fliegen es wurde auch oder
abgefeuert werden hisbolla hatte auch
versucht mehrmals m
Soldaten Terroristen einzuschleusen nach
Israel um womöglich auch solche Angriffe
durchzuführen wie es die Hamas getan hat
und Israel antwortet sofort ohne zu
zögern um wirklich auch das Signal zu
senden macht das nicht und das hat ja
US-Präsident Biden auch gesagt stop
don't do it ja es gibt zwei
Flugzeugträger im Mittelmeer ich würde
sagen diese Gefahr besteht durchaus umso
mehr wenn jetzt das kann stündlich so
Wein stündlich so sein wenn die
Bodenoffensive kommt weil das Kalkül ist
Israel ist womöglich ä schwach bzw sehr
sehr stark angiert engagiert in Gaza und
auch im Westjordanland und die Idee
dahinter bei den mullas im Iran und im
Libanon bei der Hisbollah ist diese
Schwäche auszunutzen um den jüdischen
Staat auszulöschen das muss man wirklich
so klar sagen umgekehrt müsste die
hisbolla aber ja auch wissen dass dann
von ihnen nicht viel übrig bleibt also
die hisbolla hat Regierungsbeteiligung
im Libanon Libanon ist seit Jahren im
Grunde genommen seit dem Anschlag auf
Raffi cariri ein total verlorener stat
die Frage ist was ist so und die wir s
waren gerade an der mittelfristigen es
ist wir unterhalten uns über die
mittelfristien Planung von
terroristischen Organisation aber
natürlich muss man das Mitdenken wenn
man vor die Lage kommen möchte welches
Eigeninteresse hätte die Hisbollah ich
glaube sie wissen aus ihrer jüngsten
Erfahrung dass Israel massiv
zurückschlagen wird das ist klar und
dann ist die Frage also die der Rückhalt
der hisboller in der libanesischen
Bevölkerung schwindet ist ist gering
inzwischen also welche welche
mittelfristigen Folgen hat oder ne für
für die Hisbollah selbst dann ist dann
eben schon ein sehr großer Verlass
darauf dass die mullas im Iran quasi
alles vorgeben und die hisbolla dann
komplett in der Hand haben und das sind
Abschätzungen und die die Führung der
Hisbollah ist ist schwierig das W das
werden die also rational macht es
eigentlich keinen Sinn das wusste aber
ja wirklich auch
dass werden würde und genau aber die
Irrationalitäten das ist eben jetzt
genau der Punkt also ich glaube dass wir
haben jetzt genau das in das westenest
gestoßen mit dem sich die internationale
Politik jetzt beschäftigen muss mit
welchen rationalitäten kann man planen
und auf welche Irrationalitäten muss man
sich vorbereiten oder kann man das und
das erklärt zum Teil eben auch diese ja
diese lange Überlegungsphase sowohl der
internationalen Gemeinschaft wie auch
der Führung glaube ich und alles in der
Hand hat das Regime in Teran ja
tatsächlich nicht also sowohler wie auch
Hus sind ja durchaus hinterher immer
wieder zu betonen dass sie eigenständig
agieren und nicht nur befehlsfänger aus
tean sind das aber genau vor diesem
Szenario hat Israel jetzt lieberanon
noch mal ganz explizit gewarnt und das
usmitär hat aber auch noch mal weiter äh
aufgerüstet und Flugabwehrsysteme äh
installiert ist das ein Alarmsignal dass
auch wirklich die USA sagen okay in dem
Moment wo die Bodenoffensive losgeht da
müssen wir präsent sein und in welchem
Szenario würden Sie denn zum Einsatz
kommen also im besten Fall gar nicht das
ist genau der Punkt deterrence
deterrence deterrence das ist die äh das
ist die Politik der Amerikaner sie haben
sich auch schon wehren müssen wir hatten
gerade den Jemen angesprochen also es
gibt verschiedene
raketenabwürfe aus dem Jemen die
eigentlich auch nur das Ziel haben
können irgendwo Amerikaner zu treffen
oder zumindest zu aggressieren dann gab
es Anschläge auf die amerikanischen
Stellungen in Syrien und im Irak also es
wird schon so diese die Iraner pushen
schon so diese Idee des der des der der
Provokation oder der Death by000 cuts
Strategie aber dagegen wollen die
Amerikaner einfach mit massiver Präsenz
halten im Libanon ist es schwierig weil
wir keinen usbotschafter haben wir haben
die
Botschaftsangestellten ausgeflogen es
gibt keine quasi stehende diplomatische
Präsenz daher wird jetzt auch schon
angedacht wer jetzt aus der
amerikanischen diplomatischen Elite wann
wie die Regierung die die Region quasi
noch mal auf welche Art und Weise
durchkreuzt aber erstmal sind diese
Signale sehr sehr wichtig aber der
Präsident hat in seiner Rede an die
Nationen aber auch in den anderen unter
und den anderen Botschaften immer wieder
betont es wird keine Situation geben der
die Amerikaner boots on the ground in
dem Sinne
erwägen und genau da kommt das ganze
Thema auch wieder mit Russland zusammen
weil natürlich der Iran ja auch Putin
unterstützt und Putin auch auf diese
Waffen ja ein Stück mit diesen drohen ja
die beinaher unverzichtbar geworden sind
in seinem Konflikt mit der Ukraine das
heißt was passiert in dem Moment wenn
der Iran doch stärker sichtbarer noch
wirklich äh ja sag ich mal alles gegen
Israel unterstützt also noch sichtbarer
als ohnehin schon
was passiert dann muss Putin sich dann
auch Einschalten
wahrscheinlich erstens ist es eine rein
Spekulation wir wissen ja wie zum Teil
unpopulär eine Idee eines invasions
eines Krieges mit Israel im Iran also
unter der dortigen Bevölkerung ist
zweitens
ist die große Frage inwi weit Putin
nicht rhetorisch äh nicht vor einer
Fernsehkamera sondern buchstäblich
einschalten kann wie wo wo wo inwi weit
seiner Möglichkeiten begrenzt oder
unbegrenzt sind natürlich äh wird es für
ihn eine wunderbare Gelegenheit sein äh
wie gesagt die Geschichte mit der
Ukraine rumzublättern oder zumindest
versuchen das zu tun wir erinnern uns an
die Kampagne in Syrien die zum Teil
genau dieses Ziel hatte äh ein bisschen
die Aufmerksamkeit von dem ersten ischen
Krieg in der Ostukraine abzulenken und
mit dem angeblichen Kampf gegen den
islamistischen Terrorismus die
Aufmerksamkeit und das Vertrauen des
Westens
zurückzugewinnen diesmal wird es glaube
ich viel
komplizierter für ihn der Spielraum ist
viel enger inwi weit er überhaupt vom
techeran in so eine Situation gehört
wird oder nicht das lässt sich sehr sehr
zweifeln und ich würde sagen sagen dass
das was wir von ihm und von Moskau hören
das bezieht sich viel mehr auf eine Art
Rhetorik und auf eine Art hallo ich bin
da als auf seiner echten praktischen
technischen Instrumente
die Moskau zur Verfügung hätte aber und
je stärker Iran aus dieser Sache im
Moment herausgeht und im Moment sieht es
tatsächlich so aus als ginge Iran aus
der Sache gestärkt heraus desto besser
ist es natürlich für Putin weil Iran ein
großer Unterstützer Putins im
ukrainekrieg ist und nicht nur den
Waffensystem sondern sie haben ihre
Banksysteme zusammengelegt ne sie machen
also alles was Herr Putin noch handeln
kann läuft über quasi das iranische das
iranische also ne die iranische Version
von SWIFT weil er da ja schnell
ausgeschlossen wurde und und und also es
positioniert Iran auf eine ganz
gefährliche Art und Weise und Herr Putin
und S noch mal um den Punkt der Rhetorik
zu unterstreichen der ja immer sagend
sagen würde der Westen hat keine
Glaubwürdigkeit mehr der Westen
korrumpiert sich und Z stört sich selbst
er weiß in anderen Momenten darauf hin
wie eine uneingeschränkte Solidarität
mit Israel ja irgendwie die die
moralische Korruption des Westens in der
Ukraine unterstreicht weil wenn Israel
dann hingeht und Wasser und
äh Grundnahrungsmittel
den Palästinensern war wegnimmt dann sei
doch das zu vergleichen mit dem was in
der Ukraine also es wirden überall
moralische Äquivalenzen geschmiedet die
dann jetzt bestimmte Aktionen oder
Reaktionen recht fertigen werden das
heißt der disinformationskrieg der
rhetorikkrieg der Krieg um
quasi das Erfassen einer
Systemarchitektur auf der einen Seite
die westlich geprägt ist oder eine in
der die autoritären Mächte quasi den den
den rhetorischen Rahmen auch setzen der
läuft bereits sehr sehr stark der läuft
intensiv und es ist ja auch das was
Anthony blinken gesagt hat ne israel hat
jedes Recht die Hamas zu bekämpfen wie
Israel das tut ist wichtig ähm wie viel
Einfluss hat Amerika denn exakt auf die
Art und Weise wie Israel jetzt vorgeht
also ich glaube sie w sie probieren
alles
weil sie vor allen Dingen auch über die
Gesamtregion nachdenken wollen und über
die Stabilität der israelischen
Regierung an sich also noch mal
zurückgegriffen
in dieser Regierungskonstellation hatte
es Joe Biden besonders schwer wir haben
eine trumpadministration davor gesehen
die über die Abraham accords eine ganz
andere Politik gefahren sind und
gefahren haben die grundsätzliche
Sequenzierung die quasi im Nahen Osten
dastand dass man erst die Frage das
Ausgleichs zwischen den Israelis und den
Palästinensern lösen müsste bevor es zu
einem Ausgleich zwischen Israel und
anderen arabischen Staaten kommen müsste
das hat quasi die die Diplomatie der
Amerikaner jedenfalls die lange lange
laufende Logik der zwei staatenlösung
und dieser Sequenzierung auf den Kopf
gestellt das waren Realitäten mit denen
beiden jetzt erst einmal arbeiten musste
vermutlich in den ersten zwei Jahren
seiner Amtszeit zu langsam gearbeitet
hat bzw sich erstmal auf den Saudi Deal
auch konzentriert hat und und und und
jetzt aber am Reisbrett auch mit dieser
israelischen Regierung mit der er es
nicht einfach hatte und richtigerweise
nicht einfach hatte da sitzen in einer
israelischen Regierung eben auch
demokratiefeinde das wissen wir wegen
der
der Justizreform und anderen ansetzen
ähm zu schauen wie er einwirken kann auf
diese Strategie daher immer das
öffentliche Tonen nicht Fehler zu machen
die in der internationalen Politik schon
begangen worden sind die dann jahrelange
Kriege erzeugt haben gleichzeitig wird
in Teilen dieses mahnen und dieses
darauf hinweisen auch in Israel kritisch
gesehen als
ein das sozusagen hat man selbst auf dem
Schirm und braucht nicht
die Erinnerung von außen wie ist das wie
WD es gab den Hinweis von uspräsident
beiden an die Isra elische Regierung wir
haben das allergrößte Verständnis für
eure Reaktion aber haltet euch an das
Völkerrecht da ist die Antwort
der Israelis ja natürlich was denn sonst
wir sind eine Demokratie und ich glaube
da ist das be Fremden in Israel nach
allen was wir hören nicht groß es gibt
eine Ausnahme wenn diese Ermahnung
dieses belehren aus Deutschland kommt
und da finde ich ist dieses Befremden
von israelischer Seite auch sehr berecht
gerechtfertigt weil insbesondere von
deutscher Seite braucht es diesen
Hinweis braucht es diese Belehrung nicht
ähm und ja das ist auch ein Stück weit
Medien schälte Kollegens schälte jetzt
von mir vielleicht unangenehm aber es
ist muss sein ist angebracht also am Tag
des blutigen Massakers selbst ein
geschätzter Kollege von der Süddeutschen
Zeitung Peter Münch wenige Stunden
danach geschrieben dieses Massaker
spielt den Israelis der israelischen
Regierung in die Hände und jetzt muss
ich Israel an das Völkerrecht halten
also das ist wirklich ein Beispiel ähm
ja was Israel nicht braucht und was auch
nicht gerechtfertigt ist und auch
amoralisch ist von amerikanischer Seite
äh wird das in Israel ja einfach als m
Hinweis unter Freunden unter Verbündeten
aufgenommen aber kommen wir noch mal
genau zu dem was jetzt bevorsteht äh sie
sagten eben israel hat gar keine andere
Wahl als diese massive Bodenoffensive zu
starten ähm gleichzeitig ist der
Gazastreifen ein Gebiet wo es einfach
unfassbar schwierig wird aufgrund der
gegeben halten diese Bodenoffensive so
zu machen dass sie eben ja
Zivilisten schonen kann
frau klü eschbruck schüttelte auch
gerade schon so ein bisschen den Kopf
als ich sagte oder ihre Worte wiederholt
habe es gibt keine andere Wahl sehen Sie
eine andere Wahl na ja es wird
zumindest es wird in Amerika es wird
innerhalb des state departments es wird
innerhalb dieser Shuttle diipomatie sehr
sehr stark überlegt wer wer könnte
könnten die Saudis z.B noch eine Rolle
spielen wer könnte sich mit einem
Gewicht noch so reinlegen dass es eine
Möglichkeit gäbe dass die Ägypter haben
natürlich in Anführungszeichen die haben
noch nicht mal Interesse daran die
Amerikaner aus dem Gasastreifen
rauszuholen das gerade für die
Amerikaner sehr sehr schwierig welche
Lösung könnte es geben entweder
Zivilisten rauszuholen Schutzschirme
daazu also zu bauen aber eben weil die
Hammers wie man so schön sagen würde
vielleicht embeddet ist in der
Zivilgesellschaft wie könnte man das
rausfiltern aber Paul Krugman hat ein
OPED geschrieben vor einigen Tagen in
der New York Times in dem er sagt wenn
wir jetzt eine weitere wenn diese Pause
länger dauern würde wen würde das welche
welche Erleichterung würde den Eltern
der IDF Soldaten zukommen welche
Erleichterung würde der Zivilbevölkerung
im Gasastreifen zukommen welche
Erleichterung würde der internationalen
Gemeinde Gemeinschaft zukommen gäbe es
nicht noch andere Arten und Weisen das
diplomatisch noch mal anzugehen und wer
könnte da ein einmal auch
zu ihnen gefragt Frau amipur gibt es aus
ihrer Sicht andere Wege das jetzt zu
lösen oder muss Israel auch dieses
Zeichen der Stärke senden aufgrund der
Massivität und Grausamkeit der
Terrorangriffe die am 7 Oktober passiert
sind wahrscheinlich muss es dieses
Zeichen tatsächlich senden so schlimm
das für die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza
sein wird aber Israel gilt jetzt
insgesamt in der islamischen Welt als
ein geschwächter Gegner und das kann
Israel sich nicht erlauben also auch im
Hinblick auf zukünftige Vereinbarung
israel muss schon stark daastehen aber
wie das bewerkstelligt werden kann ohne
dass es so viele Opfer geben wird dass
dann die vielzitierte arabische Straße
aktiv wird und wie wie man das machen
will das
ist ein riesengroßes rel auch ja schon
richtig aber auch dazu sagen dass die
vielzitierte arabische Straße so oder so
gegen den jüdischen Staat Israel eben
auf die Straße geht und protestiert egal
was Israel macht ist das egal was Israel
macht kann man das so ja das ist richtig
also selbst wenn dann irgendwann
rauskommt dass es doch nicht die
Israelis waren die das Krankenhaus in
Gaza beschossen haben dann ist das noch
lange dann heißt es noch lange nicht
dass es wirklich auf der arabischen
Straße ankomt da werden trotzdem die
Israelis dafür verantwortlich gemacht
dass ist schon auf jeden Fall so aber
man muss sich ja auch fragen ob man
wirklich eine Perspektive hat diesen
Krieg dann in in in Gaza zu gewinnen mit
der hiszbollah hat man sich auch vor 15
Jahren überlegt man muss die hiszbollah
komplett ausschalten eine Woche später
hieß es dann ja wir wollen die
Kapazitäten der hiszbollah reduzieren
und seitdem sitzen sie in jeder
Regierung im Libanon also so einfach wie
wie man das dann denkt und wie man sich
ausdenkt das wäre das das das Beste was
der israelischen Gesellschaft passieren
könnte wenn sie ausgeschaltet wären so
einfach ist es dann eben am Boden nicht
und das wird sich gen ganz kurz
vielleicht noch mal Herr goldenzweig
auch reinholen kann man eine
Organisation wie die Hamas überhaupt
militärisch ausschalten oder ist nicht
das was die Hamas am meisten schwächen
würde tatsächlich ein wie auch immer
gearteter versuch da eine Lösung zu
finden ich bin der letzte der den
Pressesprecher von unseren Präsidenten
Herrn peskov zitieren würde aber in dem
Fall mache ich also das sind
schreckliche Terroranschläge sagt er und
natürlich benutzt auf eine zynische
Weise die ganze Situation aber zum Teil
hat er recht ind dem er und offizielle
Kremel sagt äh ja wir verstehen dass es
eine reine Instrumentalisierung aber
trotzdem wir müssen nicht die
Vorgeschichte vergessen die
Vorgeschichte des Konflikts und eine
Gewalt an sich ist
in dem Zusammenhang ich bin kein Israeli
kein Palästinenser ich kann das nur von
von außen beobachten
ist keine keine Lösung das ist nur
wiederum eine Hilfe eine Chance
ein Gewinnspiel für die Diktatoren wie
Putin um
andere Kriegsverbrechen zu relativieren
es ist uns wurscht es es un absolut egal
wir dieses Krankenhaus im Gazastreifen
abgeschossen hab ob es Israelis waren
oder arabe hauptsache es spielt uns in
den Karten und diese Gewalt alleine
fürchte ich ist keine
keine hilsreiche Lösung auf Dauer ja
jetzt ist es einfach eine Notwendigkeit
und die politische Führung sitzt ja
nicht mal in Gasa
Hania Pendel zwischen zwischen Katar und
unserem natooverbündeten Türkei hin und
her also der wird der wird ja bleiben
den wird man n nicht so einfach
ausschalten können und jedes tote Kind
das aus den Trümmern von Gaza heraus in
gazastadt herausgezogen wird wird zu
mehr Radikalisierung führen und dann
gehen die Menschen nicht mehr so Hamas
dann sind sie gleich beim Islamischen
Jihad die noch mal eine Nummer radikaler
sind radikalisiert ist die
Zivilbevölkerung ja auch das finde ich
gehört kann man auch nicht oft genug
betonen und gehört auch zur Wahrheit
dazu es wurde gefragt was ist denn die
Perspektive wenn Israel das Militär die
Hamas im Gazastreifen ausschalten könnte
wir reden viel über die Zivilbevölkerung
so in Gaza sozusagen als Objekt aber
nicht als Subjekt ich weiß dass die
Hamas die allerblutigsten Terroristen
sind
es ist ein bisschen analog zu der
Situation im Iran es ist natürlich
leicht gesagt Zivilbevölkerung erhebt
euch gegen eure Diktatoren aber was viel
zu wenig betont wird die
Zivilbevölkerung steht schon auch in
großen Teilen klar das spielt Propaganda
auch eine große Rolle und Desinformation
aber die stehen schon stehen auch schon
hinter den hammas Terroristen und da wä
es m weil gefragt wurde was ist die
Perspektive die Perspektive ist der
Gazastreifen könnte wenn es diese
Führung nicht gebe wirklich ja ein
zweites Beirut sein wie früher und
das wäre die Perspektive dass die
Zivilbevölkerung auch sagt wir möchten
uns entledigen von diesen Terroristen
wir möchten Freiheit wir möchten Frieden
wir möchten Kontakt zu Israel wir
möchten eine freie Wirtschaft wer geht
denn in die Lücke wenn die wenn die
Hamas tatsächlich
so geschlagen werden könnte wer würde
denn in diese Lücke treten im
haserstreffen also ja das ist eben genau
der also so Zivilbevölkerung möch wir
erstmal noch mal sagen dass ihr
natürlich in seit Jahren in
Abhängigkeitsverhältnissen auch zur
Hamas gesetzt sind weil die Hamas das
was an internationalen Unterstützung in
im gaserstreifen ankommt für sich
pervertiert nutzt sozialinfrastrukturen
ausbaut auf der Basis von also da D wä
ich sehr vorsichtig mit diesen blanket
statements in anfühungszeichen aber ich
glaube eine Sache oder Grund warum
ständig betont wird seitens der
Amerikaner wir haben nach dem 11
September Fehler gemacht weil daraus der
längste Krieg der USA entstand in den
die USA verwickelt war und dann auch
nicht rauskam dem Afghanistankrieg also
der grundsätzliche Punkt ist noch mal
ich glaube das was gerade in den
Hinterzimmern verschiedentlich läuft ist
zu überlegen wie sieht eine
mittelfristige Lösung aus kann man eine
israelische Regierung dieser
Konstellation noch in irgendeiner Weise
dazu bringen zu sagen wir haben auch
Interessen daran äh äh wenn es nicht
eine explizite Zweistaatenlösung ist
aber eine Lösung zu finden die
mittelfristig dazu führt dass es eine
Koexistenz geben kann gibt es irgendeine
ein ein eine nicht nur rhetorische aber
auch ernstgemein politische Perspektive
die quasi schon an den an den nächst an
den an den Status dan Naach denken
lassen würde um schon zu schauen was
gibt es für
Möglichkeiten wie wie der wie dieser
Gazastreifen weil die Israelis wollen
den Gazastreifen ja auch nicht auf
besetzen und dann mit den entsprechenden
Problemen umgehen ich glaube das ist das
was jetzt
wirklichade alles richtig Koexistenz mit
Terroristen wir haben es nicht zum
ersten Mal gesehen schwierig ja das ist
das ist ich würde gerne ansetzen bei dem
Herr Engel was sie glaube ich gerade
angedeutet haben außer ich habe es
falsch verstanden nämlich dass es eine
parallele gibt zwischen der iranischen
Zivilbevölkerung oder der iranischen
Bevölkerung und dem Regime und wie sie
dann doch irgendwie hinter diesem Regime
stehen würden und diese Propaganda
mittragen würden was sie meiner Ansicht
nach nicht tun also diese iranische
Missverständnis okay aber dann wäre ich
vielleicht wieder bei Beier
längerfristigen Perspektive denn gerade
diese iranische Bevölkerung steht nun
wirklich gar nicht hinter dem was das
Regime treibt in Gaza oder mit der
hisbolla und und mit allen anderen
Stellvertretern die sie noch so auf der
Welt etabliert haben also eine ein
Spruch weder Libanon Quatsch doch wieder
Libanon noch Gaza mein Herz gehört nur
Iran ist einer den hören wir seit 2009
also insofern wäre eine länger pektive
vielleicht tatsächlich genau diese
Zivilgesellschaft zu stärken gegen das
Regime denn dann hätte man längerfristig
aber das sind nun wirklich sehr sehr
längerfrissiges Szenarien einfach nicht
mehr dieses terrorunterstützende Regime
an der Macht und da müsste in diese
Richtung müsste man vielleicht
Weiterdenken dann machen wir für ein
Moment mal kurz an der Stelle eine
Unterbrechung und holen die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuhörer mit rein und
ich begrüße an der Stelle hilegard
Bäumel aus Würzburg guten Tag ja guten
Tag in die Runde ich habe zur Frage was
hat dazu beigetragen ihrer Meinung nach
dass die Hamas in Gaza so erstärken
konnte ja danke für die Frage fr wollen
sie antworten
m nun ja es gab Wahlen
2007 und nachdem die die
Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde die
die Ver völlig korrupt und diskreditiert
war sind die Menschen in Scharen
hingegangen unter und haben die Hamar
gewählt
und durch ja so eine kurze Frage ist das
eigentlich nicht BZ kurze Frage mit der
ewig ewig langen Antwort und dadurch
dass du wirklich eine eine schlechte
Politik gemacht wurde gegenüber dem
Gazastreifen aber auch im Gazastreifen
selbst hat die Hamas durchaus an an
Zulauf gewonnen und das hat zu einer
Radikalisierung beigetragen genauso wie
es jetzt wiederum zu einer
Radikalisierung beitragen wird wenn wir
die ersten Kinderleichen sehen in in in
gazastad
danke soweit und wir hören mal Frank
Knut aus Berlin guten Tag Herr Knut ja
schönen guten Tag schönen guten Tag die
Runde meine Frage ganz kurz es soll ja
Israel nach der seitung des heramas
möglichst in Frieden leben und ist dann
nicht eigentlich notwendig absolute zwei
staatenlösung weil sonst wird es kein
Frieden geben nur wenn die auch sagen
gut die Palästinenser haben jetzt
bestimmte Sache erreicht ist vielleicht
auch der Hass zu brechen der jetzt
entsteht durch die Opfer die
notwendigerweise durch den Krieg auch
entstehen ja wer mag Antworten
W sie Hel ja gern also mus müsste man
eigentlich weiter ausholen ähm
natürlich hat die aktuelle israelische
Regierung es komplett versäumt und es
ist auch nicht in Ihrem Interesse die
friedensbemühung
ja zu erhöhen und eine zweist
staatenlösung anzustreben und ja
abstrakt gesprochen natürlich eine zwei
staatenlösung wäre das allerallerbeste
aber auch alle anderen viel viel
besseren israelischen Regierungen in der
Vergangenheit haben alles haben wirklich
viel dafür getan dass es zu so einer
Lösung kommt aber da gibt es ja noch
eine andere Seite und ja ich kann mich
nur wiederholen also eine Lösung zu
finden mit Terroristen in Gaza und aber
auch mit es wird immer als gemäßigte
politische Kraft genannt die vertach im
Westjordanland ist
schwierig und aus königsbrunnen bei
Augsburg Frau Silvester guten Tag ja
guten Tag ja ich chte wenn Israel diese
bodenintensiv Bodenoffensive durchführt
wie geplant und das eventuell zu 100.000
bis 300.000 Toten Palästinensern kommt
und zu einer totalen Zerstörung der
Infrastruktur dann könnte Israel
verlieren nicht militärisch aber
verlieren im
Ansehen ich denke mir der der die
sogenannte westliche Welt wird noch
dabei stehen aber die islamistische Welt
hat sich ja jetzt schon abgewandt und
was ist mit dem sogenannten globalen
Süden Afrika die afrikanischen Länder
Lateinamerika die ja zi D
Generationen vorher ausgebeutet worden
sind ähnliches Schicksal haben die
werden das Ansehen wird wird verloren
sein und ich hoffe es kommt nicht zu
dieser Bodenoffensive ich meine die G
die die präsid der der westlichen
Staaten die jetzt versucht haben zu
vermitteln
möchten ja auch gerne die
bodensoffensive verhindern und ich
möchte also ich wünsche dass das auch
verhindert wird danke Frau Silvester für
diesen spannenden Gedanken auch was das
ganze mit einer Bodenoffensive noch mal
in Staaten wie Afrika auslösen wird wo
Putin natürlich auch schon vorher ja
immer so ein bisschen versucht hat das
Bild zu erzeugen dass der Westen ähm ja
ein Stück weit auch mit mit Doppelmoral
in Anführungszeichen unterwegs sein ja
und wo er die Aufmerksamkeit und das
Vertrauen mit dem Geld und nicht mit der
Gewalt versucht zu gewinnen ja wenn wir
die afrikanische Länder
erwähnen ja wie gesagt
ich fürchte das alleine mit der Gewalt
lässt sich so einer Barbarei die wir
im
neahen Osten dieser Tage gesehen haben
nicht bekämpfen die Frage ist offen okay
was ist das Resultat was ist das
Ergebnis äh so einer
großen
Bodenoffensive und
anderserseits äh
das das ist natürlich so ein pandorabox
für andere Konflikte nicht nur für die
Ukraine das ist so ein Riss zwischen dem
sogenannten zivilisierten Welt und
zwischen der sogenannten äh Achse der
bösen aber wer ist derjenige die
feststellt wir die Bösen sind wir wir
wir die Barbaren sind wir nicht das ist
das das bringt uns eigentlich nicht
nahe am Ziel anderserseits ist natürlich
Israel in so einer Situation in der er
in der der Stadt handeln muss und da
also die Lage ist mehr als schwierig
ganz kurz noch Herr Engel wir müssen
allerings ein vielle zu der Frage ich
glaube es ist ein frommer Wunsch dass
Israel im ja viel zitierten globalen
Süden und das Stichwort muslimische
islamische Straße äh kam auch schon vor
irgendetwas richtig machen kann Israel
ist sich wirklich durchaus bewusst also
es gibt nicht die perfekte Lösung es
gibt nur die am wenigsten schlechteste
Lösung wie der vorretner goldenweig
gesagt hat Israel muss reagieren und
nach allem was wir hören Israel war noch
nie so entschlossen ja diesen Terror
jetzt m ja mit Gewalt eben auch zu
begegnen ganz kurz halber Punkt wir
haben die diplomatischen Möglichkeiten
noch nicht ausgeschöpft die USA muss
weiter global arbeiten was gerade auf
dem Spiel steht ist nämlich der Israel
brückenknopf von Indien nach Israel nach
Europa das große Projekt was China
entgegentreten sollte was die
Seitenstraße einging also da muss noch
nachgearbeitet werden und die EU wo ist
eigentlich die EU die EU könnte
zumindest jetzt im Moment auch was die
Geiseln angeht eine treuka Stellen
Deutschland Frankreich Polen mit den USA
an der Seite um sich in den ganz
bestimmten Bereichen wo sie ein züngler
an der Waage haben nicht erst im
Wiederaufbau wie es traditionell war
sondern sich jetzt in diese Situation
reinzuhnen danke soweit und wir gehen zu
jürgenend klein nach Siegburg guten Tag
Herr Klein ja einen schönen guten Tag in
die Runde ist eine frage mich jetzt
schon seit 14 Tagen
bewegt ich sag mal der israelische
Geheimdienst und die
Sicherheitsbehörden gehören nach meinem
Wissen zu den besten der Welt und das
einzige was einfach nicht meine
Vorstellungskraft geht ist die Frage ob
es nicht doch von in israelischen
Sicherheitsbehörden früher gemerkt wurde
dass so viele Terroristen sich an der
Grenzen bewegen und dass Netanyahu aus
innenpolitischen grüen ich sag mal etwas
verzögert gewartet hat ohne natürlich zu
wissen welche Eskalation dadurch
entsteht diese Frage die lässt mich
nicht los vielleicht haben wir eine
Antwort darauf der möchte Antworten ich
glaube das geht übelst in Richtung
Verschwörungstheorie und sie waren sich
wahrscheinlich zu sicher sie müssen sie
es ist inzwischen klar dass sie auch von
den Ägyptern gewarnt worden sind aber
ich glaube sie fühlten sich so sicher
dass sie dachten das kann nicht das kann
nicht sein wir werden das wir werden das
wir werden zurückschlagen können aber
mit sowas haben sie ganz offensichtlich
nicht gerechnet übrigens nicht nur ein
Scheitern der israelischen Geheimdienste
sondern auch der amerikanischen
Geheimdienste und ja es kann ich glaube
Israel war in den vergangenen Monaten
sehr sehr stark mit sich selber
beschäftigt sehr sehr stark also wo es
auch in den Sicherheitsbereich
reingegangen ist
m und also Stichwort Justizreform und ja
expert in Israel sagen dass das eine
Menge Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen
hat was dann in dieser großen
Katastrophe womöglich dann geändert
hat und Frau Adams aus neustadtwied
guten Tag Frau Adams ja guten Tag in die
Runde und zwar habe ich eine
Frage das betrifft also die alle
Journalisten in der Runde
und ich denke dass in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten also seit der Gründung des
States Israel
1948 aber auch schon vorher der Terror
der sich gegen die palästinensische
Bevölkerung gerichtet hat einfach
nicht genug thematisiert wird also
ich verabschaue jegliche physische und
psychische Gewalt aber ich muss sagen es
hat mich nicht gewundert dass jetzt so
ein schwerwiegender Angriff gegen Israel
stattgefunden hat
ähm das
habe ich eigentlich schon länger
erwartet weil es ist so dass auch nicht
alles Land was die Palästinenser
abgegeben haben oder abgeben mussten
dass das freiwillig war zum Teil Frau
Adams ich glaube der Punkt ist
angekommen man muss natürlich ganz klar
sagen dass nichts aber auch wirklich gar
nicht so ein Terrorangriff rechtfertigt
dennch die Frage von Frau Adams glaub es
gibt eine klare Antwort mich hat es auch
nicht überrascht schauen Sie nach in der
Karte der Hamas also dort steht das
oberste Ziel ist Israel den jüdischen
Staat auszulöschen und möglichst viele
Juden zu ermorden ja es hat tatsächlich
nicht überrascht da haben Sie Recht und
dann hören wir mal Herrn Hagen aus vzeim
guten Tag Herr Hagen einen wunderschönen
guten Tag in die Runde eine mögliche
Bodenoffensive könnte ja den Protest der
in Deutschland auch stattfindet noch
weiter befeuern der Bundeskanzler möchte
schärfere Maßnahmen nur es passiert ja
überhaupt nichts das heißt
man müsste diese gewalttätigen Leute
einsammeln
erkennungsdienstlich behandeln warum
werden die nicht abgeschoben
umgehen in ihre Heimatländer ja das ist
eine Diskussion die natürlich jetzt in
Deutschland stattfindet wenn es
Ausschreitung gibt es gab ja auch
gestern in London eine riesige
Demonstration europaweit ja
Herrig also ich habe viele
russlandstämigen jüdischen Bekannten und
Freunde die äh nach dem Kriegsausbruch
äh in der Ukraine aus politischen
Gründen oder aus Sicherheitsgründen nach
Deutschland äh ausgewandert sind oder
mehrere Jahre hier schon verbracht haben
und für sie entsteht eigentlich die
Frage diese Tage ob sie ein richtiges
Land gewählt haben das ist
erschreckend und das ist eben der Riss
den ich erwähnt habe der geht nicht nur
durch Israel sondern durch die ganze
durch die ganze Welt äh äh ob es ein
winziges eine winzige Flecke Landes
Gasastreifen ist mit 2 Millionen
Menschen oder oder ob es
arabischprachige Minderheiten in Europa
sind also das wird sehr kompliziert zu
trainen wir hier Extremisten sind wer
sich radikalisiert hat und wer steht auf
der Seite von Palästina und mehr Gewalt
wird fürchte ich nur noch mehr Gewalt
außerhalb von Israel schaffen ja noch
kurz also ist ist Sache deutscher
Gerichte zu entscheiden aus welchen
Gründen man abgeschoben werden kann das
ist das eine das andere ist ich finde
sie machen den zweiten Schritt vor dem
ersten wieso setzen sie denn voraus dass
das WN nicht Deutsche sind die auf die
Straßen gehen und und demonstrieren also
das sind ja nicht notwendigerweise
geflüchtete aus dem Nahen Osten die
einen unsicheren
aufenalstus danke für die Erläuterung
noch und wir hören noch Mark heben aus
erdenberg guten Tag ja hallo aus Hessen
in die Runde zwei kleine Fragen erstens
die Kontrolle der scheibchenweise
gelieferten LKWs der
Hilfstransporte warum können
internationale nicht zu 100% feststellen
wohin Diesel etc geliefert wird das wäre
die eine Frage ansonsten könnten ja 200
weitere LKWs reinfahren aber die dann
eventuell die Hammers abreien die zweite
Frage habe ich im öffentlich rech
gesehen wie kann es sein dass aus
Wasserleitungen die aus Deutschland
kommen in Tunnel der Hammers zu Raketen
umfunktioniert werden das wäre die Frage
ja wer mag antworten wir haben nicht
ersten Punkt vielleicht ganz kurz das
ist genau das was angedacht wird wie
können genau diese Hilfskonvois bis
quasi zu den reziptienten kontrolliert
werden und welche Rolle können da
besonders internationale Organisationen
spielen ganz weit vorne natürlich das
Internationale Rote Kreuz und die UNO
bzw unw die für bei der UNO bestimmt
abgestellte Hilfsorganisation für die
Palästinenser noch eine Ergänzung die
hilfskonvoys sind nicht das Problem die
Gelder sind das Problem die dann
missbraucht werden ja für terroristische
Zwecke das in der Tat und da ist ja auch
schon besprochen worden dass das alles
noch mal ganz genau unter den Prüfstand
kommt was wohin fließt wir schaffen
wahrscheinlich nicht noch eine komplette
Frage kurze letzte Einschätzung zum
Schluss schaff man es dass ja die USA
und der Westen sowohl die Ukraine im
Blick halten und jetzt auch die
notwendige Unterstützung im Nahen Osten
liefern vielleicht Herr goldenzweig mit
dem Blick um eine ganz bitte eine ganz
kurze Einschätzung zum Schluss
kurzfristig ja mittelfristig wird es
sehr sehr schwierig die USA kann beides
leisten sie muss ihre innenpolitische
Probleme dringend lösen und sie muss
bedacht einen neuen Präsidenten im
November 2024 wählen besten Dank für die
Einschätzung und die Diskussion heute
ihnen vielen Dank fürs zusehen bleiben
Sie jetzt bei phöniix wir bleiben
aktuell beim Thema und zeigen Ihnen auch
live die Kundgebung für Israel die heute
in Berlin stattfindet danke aus
[Musik]
Köln